翻訳: Koichiro YODA
校正: Kyoko Kamura
私は普段
日本の超ド田舎を回って
旅行業アドバイザーという
仕事をしています
どれくらい田舎なのかといいますと
最寄り駅から車で２時間とか
フェリーで５時間かかる離島とか
そういう所ばっかり行って
お仕事させて頂いているんですけれども
こういう所っていうのは大体
もう 何をやっても反対されるんですよ
新しいことをしようものなら
まぁ 大体 反対されるんですね
で そういう反対している人を
味方に変えるという活動をやっています
今日はその活動について
お話しさせて頂きます
でもですね
「別に反対しても無視して
やったらいいやん」とお思いの方
いらっしゃると思うんですね
私も最初 そう思いました
でも こういう田舎では
そうはいかないんです
というのも 今 日本の田舎というのは
移住促進をしています
で Ｉターンとか
地域おこし協力隊とか
そういうのを聞かれた方
いらっしゃると思うんですけれども
こういう方たちは新しい仕事を
自分で作り出さないといけないんですね
なので その土地に
縁もゆかりも無い上に
周りの協力も無いとなると
本当に辛いんです
じゃあ どれくらいの人が
反対するのかといいますと
こういう反対されている人
何人かに話を聞いてみたんですけども
もちろん人によって差はありますが
平均すると なんと
９割の人が反対するんだそうです
もう ほとんどが反対です
しかもですね
わざわざ家までやってきて
「お前のは間違ってる」みたいな
こうグイグイ反対してくるんですね
もう 説教するぐらいの感じで
今 日本の田舎で
新しいことをしようと思うと
味方がほとんどいないというのが
今の日本の田舎の現状です
で こういう人たちというのはですね
ここまで反対されると
やっぱり だんだん「やめようかな」
という気になってくるんですね
私は そのくじけそうになってる人の
涙をたくさん見てきました
もう「なんとかしないといけない！」
ということで
一旦 話を聞いてもらう場を
作ろうと思ったのが
この活動を始めたきっかけでした
ところで
だいたい こういうことを
反対する人っていうのは
年配の男性なんですよ
こういう方たちのことを
最大限の愛を込めて
「じじい」と呼んでいます
（笑）
今からですね 急に
じじいと言い始めますけども
品を失う感じになりますけども
許してください
で このじじいたちをですね
なんとか黙って話を聞かせたいと
黙らせたいっていう
感じなんですね 私は
で 最初はよくある否定NGの
ブレインストーミングみたいな
否定をやめましょうみたいな感じに
やったんですけども
じじいたち 全然人の話
聞きませんでした
じじいって人の話
聞かないじゃないですか
聞かないですよね？
ほらね 頷いてますよね
ほんと聞かないんですよ
で 人の話を聞くふりして
「俺の若いときはこうやったんや」みたいな
結局 自分の自慢話をするというですね
こういうことになりまして
で こうなったら私も意地ですよ
もう なんとかして黙って話を
聞かせたいということになりまして
禁断の「過去の話封じ」をしました
で 過去の話を封じたら
黙ると思うじゃないですか
そうするとですね
やっぱり うまくいったんです
ある程度の方が黙ってくださいました
この「過去の話封じ」っていうのは
年齢が行けば行くほど
きついルールなんですね
私ぐらいの年齢の人でも
「過去の話封じられたら
何も話すことないわ」という方
いらっしゃるんですけど
お若い方っていうのはですね
何の苦労もなく さらーっと
未来の話だけできるという
すごい 一旦やっていただくと
わかるんですけども
「人間って歳とともに過去に引きずられて
生きているんだなぁ」ということが
よく おわかり頂けると思います
で「これはいける！」
ということになりまして
私 日本の各地を回って
仕事をしていますので
その各地で「スナックたつえ」というですね
「地域の明るい未来の話をする飲み会」
という移動スナックを各地で始めました
で このルールが
先程の「ネガティブな話をしない」
というのと「過去の話をしない」
この２つのルールでやっています
実際 どんな感じなのかといいますと
最初に「こんな感じで
ルールがあるんで守って下さいね」とか
「こんな話したらどうですか」
みたいなことをお話しさせて頂いて
次に みなさんで話し合いをします
で このときに
最初「話を聞いてもらう場を作る」
と言いましたけれども
聞き手と話し手に分かれるのではなくて
参加している老若男女の方みなさんに
ご自分の明るい未来の話を
語って頂きます
で なぜかですね
みなさん 明るい未来の話 するときは
ちょっとニヤニヤするんですね
あちこちでニヤニヤする人がいるという
とても素敵な光景です
で 最後に 前に何人かの人に
出てきて頂いて
全員で話しているわけではないので
「この人の話 素敵だな」とか
「シェアして欲しいな」っていう話の方の
お話を最後にして頂いています
で スナックたつえにはですね
なんと「チーママ制度」がありまして
「日本を世界一 チャレンジャーに
協力的な国する」っていう
ものすごい大それた目標を
掲げていまして
でも たつえママは
体一つなんですよ
だから もう限られてきてしまうので
一人でも多くの味方を
作りたいということで
チーママたちと協力してですね
この活動を広げていこうとしています
「スナックたつえをやって
どんな変化があったのか」という事例を
ご紹介させて頂きます
何年か前なんですけども
「ドローンを使ったビジネスを
したいんだけど
周りに猛反対されてるんですよね」
という相談をある青年から受けました
で 彼の話を聞いてみると
「この地方がどんどん衰退していくのを
もう見てられない」と
「だから ちょっと他とは
同じことをしたくないから
ちょっと変わったこと
思い切ったことをしたいんだ」
ということだったんですね
で まだこの時は
今ほどドローンの可能性みたいなものが
まだ報じられていない時代でした
じゃあ もうそのドローンの可能性と
あとは あなたの熱意をとにかく
聞いてもらう場を設けようということで
スナックたつえをやりました
そうするとですね
ものすごくうまくいって
「おぉ そんなことを
考えてくれてたんか！」みたいな
じじいたち一同 大感激って
感じなんですけども
で 私たち本当に嬉しかったんですけど
でも同時に「あれ？」っていう
感じだったんですね
なぜかというと
もうすでにこの話
何回もしてるんです じじいたちに
で 聞いてなかったんですよね
じじいたちの頭の中には
「え？ ラジコンみたいな
おもちゃやろう？」
「そんなんで生活できると
思ってんのか？」みたいな
でも 反対の気持ちがすごいんで
その後の話 全然耳に
入ってなかったんですよ
これが農業の話だったら
「よう言うた」ってことで
スッと耳に入ってきてた
はずなんですけども
よくわからない世界の言葉で
もう引っかかってしまってたんですね
それをもう 黙って口答えせず
最後まで聞いてもらったことによって
彼の情熱の部分とか その他の部分を
伝えることができて
協力的になってくれました
で この回ではスナックたつえを
やっている最中から
「車屋の知り合いいるから
ちょっと電話して
タダで車 出してもらえるように
言うたげるわ」みたいな感じですね
もうそのスナックたつえの最中から
電話してくれて
トントントンといろんなことが
話が進んだんですけれども
一番反対していたじじいがですね
最終的には 前のめりで手伝ってくれる
じじいに変わりました
残念ながら ビジネスとして
成功するかどうかというのは
またちょっと その先の
問題なんですけれども
協力という意味では
大変成功した例でした
で ここまで話してきてですね
私とじじいたちって
バチバチの敵対関係なんだろうと
みなさん思っていらっしゃると
思うんですけれども
実は 私とじじいたちって
仲良しなんですよ
なんでかっていうと
尊敬しているんです じじいたちのこと
さっきの車屋さんを紹介してくれる
話もそうですけど
人脈がすごいんで
何か頼るとですね
話がものすごく速く進むんですね
とかですね やっぱり年の功です
ええこと言いよるんですよ
じじいたちって
なんかこう
「最後の挨拶をお願いします」
とか言ったら
パシッと場が締まるようなことを
やっぱり言ってくれるんですね
その他もやっぱ
ほんとすごいんですよ
で そのすごい能力を
若い力に使わない
変なプライドとか誤解とかで使わないのは
本当にもったいないと私は思います
人間 ひとりの力というのは
本当に限られています
できることは微々たるものです
周囲の協力があれば
もっと力を発揮できるのではないでしょうか
さあ みなさん
これをご自分に当てはめて
考えてみてください
親子でも夫婦でも
先生と生徒でも 上司と部下でも
全く同じことが
言えるのではないでしょうか
私は 地方を回っていまして
すごい熱意で もう 本当に
すごい真面目に未来を語ってくれる若者に
たくさん出会います
彼らの話を聞く限りですね
日本の未来は
かなりの確率で明るいんですよ
あとは 私たち大人が それを
どう活かしてあげられるかだと思います
だからチャレンジしようとしていて
反対されている人は
諦めないで協力を
得て欲しいと思いますし
反対してる人も
賛成している人も
見守っている側の人はですね
もう どんなに反対していても
とにかく最後まで
話を聞いてあげて欲しいと思います
伝えるということは
大変難しいことですけれども
とても重要なことです
この「ネガティブな話をしない」
「過去の話をしない」
この２つのルールで 一度
語り合ってみてはいかがでしょうか
ありがとうございました
（拍手）